♪ ♪
>> WHEN YOU DO ALL AEOLIAN
VOTING BALLOTS, YOU ARE ASKING
FOR FRAUD.
PEOPLE STEAL THEM OUT OF
MAILBOXES.
PEOPLE PRINT THEM, AND THEN THEY
SIGN THEM AND GIVE THEM IN.
PEOPLE DON’T EVEN KNOW IF THEY
ARE DOUBLE COUNTED.
THE CALIFORNIA, THE GOVERNOR
SAID SENDING MILLIONS OF BALLOTS
ALL OVER THE STATE TO ANYBODY.
PEOPLE THAT AREN’T CITIZENS, WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DESTROY THIS
COUNTRY BY ALLOWING THINGS LIKE
THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT THE FIRST TO WARN ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF FRAUD FROM MAIL-IN
BALLOTS.
THE BIPARTISAN COMMISSION ON
FEDERAL ELECTION WAS COCHAIRED
BUT NOTED RIGHT WING OR
JIMMY CARTER.
OKAY.
IT FOUND IN 2005 THAT ABSENTEE
BALLOTS THE MAJOR SOURCE OF
VOTER FRAUD.
CITIZENS WHO VOTED HOME FROM A
NURSING HOMES COME AT THE
WORKPLACE OR CHURCH MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO PRESSURE OVERT
AND SUBTLE OR INTIMIDATION.
VOTE BUYING SCHEMES MORE
DIFFICULT TO DETECT WHEN
CITIZENS VOTE BY MAIL.
JOINING ME NOW TEXAS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR DAN DAN PATRICK.
THE GENIUSES AT TWITTER
SUBJECTED TRUMP TO THEIR FIRST
EVER FACT-CHECKED THAT IN YOUR
STATE A RECENT INVESTIGATION
DIDN’T YOU GUYS UNCOVER ALLEGED
BALLOT HARVESTING SCHEME
INVOLVING MAIL-IN BALLOTS?
>> WELL, WE FOUND MANY OVER THE
YEARS, LAURA BUT THIS STORY JUST
BROKE TONIGHT LITERALLY.
I THINK YOU’RE THE FIRST PERSON
TO TALK ABOUT AND I KNOW VERY
WELL COME A VERY GOOD CITIZEN,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER SPENT TWO
YEARS ON THIS.
SHE FOUND WHERE A DEMOCRAT
CONGRESS WOMAN IN HOUSTON PAID A
CONVICTED FORGER AND THERE WAS
ANOTHER CONVICTED FORGER WORKING
ON THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY ALSO HAVE AUDIOTAPES AND
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW TO
HARVEST THESE BALLOTS.
GROUP THEM UP IN GROUPS OF 50.
THE SIGNATURES WERE THE SAME ON
THE ENVELOPE AS THEY WERE ON
EVERY ONE OF THESE BALLOTS AND
THE BALLOT SIGNATURES.
SO LOOK, TWITTER OWES THE
PRESIDENT AN APOLOGY.
THEY FACT-CHECKED HIM LAURA FOR
HIS OPINION, AND BY THE WAY HIS
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
I JUST TWEETED OUT THAT THE
DEMOCRAT PLAN TO HAVE EVERYONE
VOTE BY MAIL AS AN INVITATION
FOR FRAUD AND IT IS A TOTAL
SCAM.
TONIGHT, I WOULD LIKE ALL OF
YOUR MILLIONS OF VIEWERS TO
TWEET THEIR OWN TWEET OUT ABOUT
HOW MAIL IN MALIN POWELL --
LET’S SEE IF THEY FACT-CHECKED
ME AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, THAT
NETWORK SAID GO TO THE WINDOW
AND
SHOUT OUT YOU ARE MAD AS HELL AN
WON’T TAKE IT ANYMORE?
THE MODERN DAY GO TO YOUR
COMPUTER MILLIONS OF TWEETS THE
DEMOCRATS PLAN, WRITE YOUR OWN
TWEET, FOLKS, SEND IT OUT AND
LET’S SEE IF TWITTER GOES AFTER
HIM LIKE THEY GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY OWE HIM AN APOLOGY.
>> Laura: HE WILL NOT GET IT
FROM JACK.
>> THEY NEED TO STOP
FACT-CHECKING OPINION.
>> Laura: ARE THEY GOING TO
FACT-CHECKED ALL THE MODELERS IN
COVID?
ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
WRONG AND OTHER DOOMSDAY
SCENARIOS?
JERRY NADLER A CONGRESSMAN
LIBERAL FROM NEW YORK SAID THIS
DAN, 2004, WATCH.
>> MY EXPERIENCE IN NEW YORK,
PAPER BALLOTS ARE EXTREMELY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD.
I WANT A PAPER TRAIL.
I WANT PAPER SOMEWHERE.
BUT PURE PAPER WITH NO MACHINES,
I CAN SHOW YOU EXPERIENCE WHICH
WOULD MAKE YOUR HEAD SPIN.
>> Laura: JERRY NADLER MIGHT
HAVE LOST A LITTLE WEIGHT SINCE
THEN BUT THE WEIGHT OF HIS
COMMENTS ARE ON TARGET THERE.
>> LAURA COME I WAS ONE OF THE
COAUTHORS OF VOTER -- PHOTO I.D.
BEFORE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AND THAT’S WHAT THEY
SAID ON THE FLOOR, THE DEMOCRATS
WE DON’T HAVE TO HAVE PHOTO
VOTER I.D. BECAUSE SCAM IS IN
THE MAIL AND MAIL-IN BALLOTS AND
WHY EVERYONE NEEDS TO VOTE BY
MAIL.
LOOK HERE IS THE DEAL THE
FURTHER AWAY YOU GET FROM THE
BALLOT BOX, THE MORE OPPORTUNITY
FOR FRAUD.
THE DEMOCRATS USED TO SAY, YOU
DON’T HAVE TO, YOU KNOW, SHOW AN
I.D. TO VOTE BUT NOW THEY DON’T
WANT YOU TO VOTE.
AS FAR AS PROTECTIONS, THEY SAY
THIS IS ABOUT SAFETY BUT NOW IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH SAFETY.
65 YEARS OLD AND OLDER CITIZENS
IN THIS COUNTRY IN TEXAS IN
ALMOST EVERY STATE CAN ALMOST
ALREADY VOTE BY MAIL.
WITH THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO IS
AUTOMATICALLY SEND OUT BALLOTS
WHICH IS AGAINST THE LAW IN
TEXAS.
YOU HAVE TO REQUEST THEM TO VOTE
BY MAIL.
THEY WANT TO SEND IT OUT TO
EVERY CITIZEN.
THIS IS THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO TRY
TO RIG THE ELECTION.
WE WILL NOT PUT UP WITH IT, AND
IF THEY GET AWAY WITH IT, LAURA,
IT IS THE END OF DEMOCRACY.
NOT JUST THE END OF THIS
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
IF THEY GET AWAY WITH THIS,
DEMOCRACY HAS BEEN SHREDDED.
>> Laura: I REMEMBER HAILING A
ROCKIES TO PULL TO THE VOTE WITH
HER PURPLE FINGERS.
THEY RISK THEIR LIVES TO VOTE.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO THEM.
WE CAN DO IT SAFELY, IN PERSON
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY THROUGH THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY IF YOU
REALLY NEED AN ABSENTEE BALLOT